before ben roethlisberger came to
pittsburgh there was an athlete who
played for the college team in town
not the carnegie mellon tartans but the
pit panthers
larry fitzgerald still going strong
still not clear whether he's going to
keep going here's his head coach in
arizona cliff kingsbury on
larry fitzgerald's future if there is
one for him in the nfl
i don't know anything but obviously it's
been an honor to come in as a young
coach from from college
um and and just the way he embraced the
coaching and offense and
his work ethic i mean he's an all-time
great there's no doubt one of the best
players to ever play the game and one of
the best people i've ever been around
just the way he treats our staff um you
know the people in the building the the
fans i mean
he's phenomenal and you know i hope he
plays five more years
i it's never been this late in the off
season that larry fitzgerald has
announced his plans for the next season
and one of the little subplots to the
j.j watts signing
peter i i feel like his arrival balances
out what you
lose from a gravitas standpoint with
larry fitzgerald if he moves on you've
got the
the man of the year patch on the jersey
that guy walks through the door just as
larry fitzgerald walks away and
you know i i he he seems like he could
still keep playing if he wants to
but it's this has been something for the
last four or five years not a brett
favre
look at me pay attention to me kind of
way but it's just been a question he's
been taking it year to year and
it just feels like this is it for larry
fitzgerald
uh if he was convinced that they could
contend for a championship maybe he'd do
it but this is a team that finished in
third place
in their division last year i said this
earlier in the week cliff kingsbury's
got his work cut out for him
because all of a sudden the bar has been
raised for a team that was eight and
eight
and and was in third place in its
division it could be in third place or
fourth place in its division this year
and a lot of people are going to be
upset if that happens because they think
jj watt
is coming to town to to take the team on
the short trip to la for the super bowl
you know there's a couple of things
about larry fitzgerald number one
um you know what regardless of how lofty
the words are
from the head coach you know the fact is
he's going to be 38 years old this year
and last year he had far and away
not even close the worst year of his nfl
career
and you know even though he had been on
this sort of plateau
mic where he was he had become a good
slot slash possession receiver
um you know last year he just was not
very
effective and when you think about uh
what he means to the organization
everybody in that organization is going
to do
right by larry fitzgerald he had a
choice
you know he could have gone somewhere he
could have gone to
a new england or and i don't even know
what team he could have gone to but
there's no question that three or four
years ago he made
the conscious decision that i am going
to be a single
market athlete that's what i'm gonna be
however long i play and so even though
it's been nine weeks
since the last game of the season and
everybody has sort of been on this larry
fitzgerald
vigil even though you you see that mike
here's the issue the issue is i i think
in a pragmatic way
can you afford one year 11 million
as a gold watch to larry fitzgerald can
you afford that this year
i haven't looked at their roster as to
who it would cost them
but that would cost them probably two
important players i'm not trying to be
dramatic
but two guys who would be among their
top
22 to 26 most important players on the
roster
they wouldn't be able to have those guys
because
of having larry fitzgerald now could you
do a contract
like you know in stretching this out
into the future
make this his last year give him a
four-year deal and then
he ends up retiring as of june 2
2022. you could do that but
is it worth it that's what you have to
ask yourself
you know i hadn't looked at his numbers
from last year my goodness career lows
in catches
targets yardage i mean he fell off
yeah 409 total yards in 13 games from
larry fitzgerald last year and one of
the rare seasons in which he played only
13 games usually it's 16 16 16 when you
look at his
career splits hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports